foreign
[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is Sky News
breakfast
extraordinary new detail has been
revealed overnight about Donald Trump's
actions on January the 6th as the former
president watched rioters storming the
capital from the dining room of The West
Wing and ignore the pleas of even his
children to tell the mob to leave he's
been accused by the inquiry
investigating the attack last year of
knowingly failing to act and instead
pouring gasoline on the Fire
also of course we're going to have all
the latest on the Tory leadership
election after this truss and Rishi
sunak's first full day of campaigning
I'll be joined by Robert Halford who's
backing Rishi sunak and Graham Stewart
who's backing Liz truss it's Friday the
22nd of July
he chose not to act Donald Trump accused
of knowingly ignoring please to call off
the rioters during the storming of the
U.S capital
the Congressional inquiry hears more
extraordinary evidence about the former
president's actions on January the 6th
as he watched the riot unfold on
television from a dining room In The
West Wing
president Trump did not fail to act
during the 187 minutes between leaving
the ellipse and telling the mob to go
home
he chose not to act
Rishi sunak and Liz truss face off in
the race for number 10 as a new poll
gives the foreign secretary a convincing
lead
school holidays get underway there's a
warning that fuel price protesters could
bring chaos to Britain's roads
turkey says a deal has been reached with
Russia to allow Ukraine to resume
exports of grain
burnt to the ground we speak to the
villagers in Spain being driven out of
their homes by Relentless wildfires
President Biden tests positive for covid
but says he's doing great
a new photograph of Prince George is
released to mark his ninth birthday
also ahead this morning we'll be
venturing into deep space ahead of the
release of a new film exploring the
mysteries of asteroids I'll be joined by
a NASA scientist and the film's director
[Music]
and I'll be joined by the nation's
favorite pianist Jules Holland to talk
about his new concert in Aid of the
fight against prostate cancer and his
personal experience of the disease
stop
now
[Music]
hello and a very good morning to you
Donald Trump has been accused of
knowingly failing to act during the
storming of the U.S capital as his
advisors and even his children urged him
to call off the mob Witnesses at another
extraordinary hearing into the events of
January the 6th have described the
former president instead watching the
events unfolding on TV from the dining
room of The West Wing Skies Sally
Lockwood reports from Washington
5-50b by the account of police one
advisor trying to breach and get to the
Capitol while this building was under
attack on January the 6th what was
Donald Trump doing the question at the
heart of this committee's investigation
now on Prime Time television this
hearing laid out what was happening
inside the White House president Trump
did not fail to act during the 187
minutes between leaving the ellipse and
telling the mob to go home
he chose not to act this committee
revealed new evidence of Trump's
inaction as he watched the riots unfold
on television from The West Wing
a 213 protesters started kicking in the
windows of the Capitol building shortly
after we see the vice president Mike
Pence being evacuated to safety by the
Secret Service
their radio recordings reveal a sense of
panic
time we may have and they lose the
ability to leave so if we're going to
leave we need to do it now one White
House security official described
anonymously how at this point staffers
were beginning to fear for their lives a
lot of very personal calls
um over the radio that they were called
to say goodbye to family member or so
and so forth
the mobs anger was directed at the vice
president but Donald Trump does not call
on them to stop instead he tweets Mike
Pence didn't have the courage to do what
should be done
then Deputy press secretary Sarah
Matthews gave unparalleled insight into
the president's reluctance to call off
the mob the president did not want to
include any sort of mention of Peace in
that tweet and it wasn't until Ivanka
Trump suggested the phrase stay peaceful
that he finally agreed to include it to
me his refusal to act and call off the
mob that day and his refusal to condemn
the violence was indefensible a day
later the agonizing and denial continued
the hearing shown outtakes of Donald
Trump's video message from January the
7th
whenever you're ready sir my only goal
was to ensure the Integrity of the vote
Congress has certified the results I
don't want to say the election Zone but
I just want to say
Congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
testimony of a desperate president on
one of the most extraordinary days in
American history Sally Lockwood Sky News
Washington
how are we going to bring you all the
latest on the conservative leadership
election in just a moment but first some
breaking news for you this morning and
we've got the latest retail sales
figures just in so let's find out what
they tell us our politics and business
correspondent Amanda acass is standing
by with all details so Amanda what are
those figures what do they tell us
yes so we can see that the figures are
down by 0.1 percent over the previous
month
um that's for sales for everything that
has been sold in shops and online fuel
everything else so overall a drop of 0.1
percent now that is actually rather less
than had been feared uh the previous
month that drop was 0.8 percent to the
month to may but obviously that does
cover the period of the Jubilee weekend
and it's suggested by retailers that
perhaps that did give it a bit of a bump
so it wasn't quite as bad as have been
expected given that we know that
inflation is obviously at record 40-year
highs of 9.4 percent announced just
earlier this week obviously people
tightening the purse strings now overall
sales are up slightly where they were
before kovid hit us back in February
2020 but they did fall over the past
year if we look at online sales
particularly they fell by 3.7 percent
fuel sale in particular have fallen by
4.3 percent obviously that's due to the
record increase in the price of fuel up
42 percent overall in terms of other
kinds of goods so
um clothing stores they fell by 4.7
household goods 3.7
um there's a real sense that perhaps
people are putting off buying more
expensive products those big items
Furniture kitchens all of that kind of
thing with the real concerns about
um the impact of the cost of living
crisis and inflation but I think
certainly this figure of overall a 0.1
percent decrease isn't as much as feared
but it's certainly given that we know
that inflation is heading to grow even
more in coming up in the autumn in
October we're expecting the bank of
England are expecting it to hit some 11
with the next energy price cap that
actually the pain isn't over yet and it
certainly looks like it could grow even
further before we're done with this and
indeed Amanda thanks very much indeed
so let's move to the race for number 10
now and after the first full day of
head-to-head campaigning the foreign
secretary Liz truss seems to be pulling
ahead with a convincing lead over her
rival Rishi sunak in the latest polling
their campaigns so far have focused on
the economy and Taxation plans as they
Vie to win the votes of conservative
party members so let's take a look at
the latest poll in more detail then and
a yougov survey of Tory members shows
that 62 percent of the party would favor
the foreign secretary as a leader that
compares to 38 he would back Rishi sunak
so that's a 24 percentage point lead for
this truss that's up from 22 days before
when the last poll was published on
Tuesday the sunac campaign argued that
they were closing the Gap but this poll
suggests otherwise
well one of Liz truss's backers is the
business secretary quasi quateng who
said no country in the world had
achieved growth by putting up taxes
what is she is very credible about is
the idea that you can't tax your way to
growth no country in the history of the
world has ever grown its economy by
simply increasing taxes and I think
there's a real fear that we've got the
70-year high in terms of tax
take and that's not something that's
sustainable in fact Boris Johnson
himself uh indicated only a few weeks
ago that he was looking to make those
tax cuts and it is we'll deliver on that
well Rob Powell is here with me now good
morning to you so what do you make of
this latest yougov poll it does give Liz
truss a real Advantage it seems yeah I
think it shows pretty clearly at the
beginning of the next stage this member
stage of the leadership contest between
Missy sunak and Liz truss let's be clear
Liz truss as it stands is the clear
favorite
um these figures show a clear golf in
terms of the members but we should point
out 730 members were polled by
um yougov so it is a fraction of the
entire uh voting
um population if you like that will make
this decision but it does show that Liz
truss at the moment is ahead and I think
one other concerning statistic for the
sunac camp is that yougov also asked the
730 members about whether both
candidates could be trusted to tell the
truth and 40 of the people those 730
members who are asked that about Rishi
sunak said they didn't think he could be
trusted to tell the truth now the figure
for Liz Trust on that was 18 so half and
I think when pitch from Rishi sunak is
about honesty about saying look I know
I'm not promising tax cuts immediately
but what I am promising is sort of
careful stewardship of the economy and
honesty about the situation we are in
the fact that that figure is quite so
high about trusting whether he's telling
the truth I think will be concerning
um again this morning I think we see
what it is going to dominate over the
next five or six weeks in the summer the
main battle line being about the economy
and being about tax with Liz truss
promising essentially a new approach to
handling the economy a new approach to
tax Rishi sunak at the moment not really
putting anything forward on top of the
previous policies that he put in when in
the treasury now we will have to see
whether he has anything in the coming
weeks to sort of bring out of his pocket
if you like to try and convince Tory
members because I think judging by these
poll numbers he needs to bring something
out interesting stuff Rob thanks very
much indeed well let's get a view on
this then shall we the conservative MP
and chair of the education select
committee Robert halfen adjoins me now
and he's backing Rishi sunak so Robert
Half and I don't know if you were
listening just then but a pretty
uncomfortable Poll for Richie sunac by
ugav of party members it gives Liz truss
a 24 point lead over the man you're
backing I mean does he have much of a
hope now well the first thing I'd say is
I'm backing with you soon act because
he's trusted in a crisis uh he developed
the furlough scheme which saved millions
of jobs and businesses around the uh
country he's being responsible about the
economy not making promises that he
can't keep we've got to cut inflation
and cut the debt then we can cut the
cost of living and cut taxes in the in
the future and also when it counts he
has cut the cost of living by cutting
taxes national insurance tax for 70 of
the um most vulnerable households around
the country he's cut he's eight million
of the most vulnerable households are
getting to get up to 1200 pounds uh back
to help them with the cost of living so
on those three things trust on the
economy trust a deal in a crisis trust
out with the car cutting the cost of
living I think which sunach is the right
person uh to help uh to help our country
to be leader of our country that's so
interesting that you talk about trust
and Trust in a crisis because a lot of
people would say we are in a crisis
we're in a cost of living crisis right
now and yet he pulls really badly on
trustworthiness for in ten say that
Rishi sunak can't be trusted to tell the
truth he he pulls much worse than Liz
trust so why do you think that is
I think there are all kinds of different
polls so for example there was a poll
out over last weekend which said that
over 70 percent of seats that were won
by the conservative in 2019 uh supported
Rishi sunak over other uh candidates so
polls come and polls go and the
important thing is that the public know
that when it counted uh will she soon
act developed the furlough scheme did
everything possible during the pandemic
and save millions of jobs and has also
done everything possible to help cut the
cost of living as well
but don't Tori members know all that
they've been watching the news they've
heard his pitch as far as
um resisting tax cuts as well and his
argument is I'm telling the unpalatable
truth he says we can't afford tax cuts
but people still don't trust him why is
that pitch not working do you think
they're very in very early days of the
contest at the moment it's only just
stuff we've only just finished the MP
elections and uh the former chances
going to be going around the country
meeting members there'll be hostings I
believe that when the charm the former
Chancellor which soon act makes his case
that more members will come and support
him because they know that he's not
making promises that he can't keep and
that's the important thing if he wanted
to be popular he could say uh everything
and anything about tax cuts but we've
got to deal with the other debt debt in
just alone is 80 billion plus over the
coming year we've got a huge problem
with inflation our prices are going up
in the supermarkets everybody knows that
things are difficult inflation is the
number one enemy of the cost of of
living and and the chancellor says we've
got to get to grips with debt and
inflation cut debt cut inflation and we
can cut uh the cost of living over the
coming months
and I want to come back to his plans on
the economy in just a moment but just
one more question on this issue of trust
is it do you think that the Tory
membership thinks that he stabbed Boris
Johnson in the back and they don't like
him for that
I don't think that's the case at all um
Richie sunak was very loyal to the Prime
Minister he resigned when he thought
things had just gone too far he had
differences with the Prime Minister over
the economy but he was there to almost
till the very very end um he was loyal
um right through the party Gate Episode
in fact there another MP went to see him
and he refused to count as any kind of
disloyalty to the to the Prime Minister
I think what people want to know is what
is the prime minister going to do the
next prime minister going to do for our
our country how um is he going to
stabilize our economy uh cut the cost
living Qatar debt uh deal with the many
other problems we face in education and
health and and I think people want to
look forward rather than discuss what's
gone on in the past
okay well let's look forward then Liz
truss says that Rishi sunak has put
taxes up to a 70-year high and has
choked off growth I mean she's got a
point hasn't she
I don't accept that narrative at all yes
he did put up a corporation attacks but
don't forget we've we spent 400 billion
pounds during uh coven I mentioned the
80 billion pounds of of debt uh interest
that we have we're two trillion pounds
in debt overall you know you have to pay
some of that money back but he also cut
taxes and this is important cut national
insurance tax for 70 of households he
also cut business taxes for Hospitality
retail and Leisure biceps taxes overall
or at a 70-year high aren't they because
we spent 400 billion pounds uh during
covert we have to pay that money back it
doesn't the money doesn't grow on tree
the chance has to be responsible but
he's cut taxes national insurance tax 70
of households cut Hospitality retail and
business taxes uh but we're using seven
billion pounds of money in order to to
do so he also overall spent 37 billion
pounds on a cost of living package so as
I mentioned 8 million of the most
vulnerable households will get up to
1200 pounds uh back everybody will get a
400 pound rebate on their energy bills
fuel Duty was cut by a five pence so
what he has done is focus tax cuts and
cost of living help with the cost of
living on the most on low earners and
the most vulnerable in our scientists
but at the same time recognizing that
because of the debt because of inflation
we have to pay that debt back somehow
and that's why he had to do what he did
with Corporation taxes
listross says that she wants to cut
taxes because it would boost growth
where are Richie sunax big ideas for
boosting growth that there aren't any
other
well that's the case the Chancellor's
talks about
um growth first of all in order to have
growth you've also got to cut inflation
and deal with the debt and you can't
just wish this away we also have to
spend money on public services so if you
don't uh just I mean if I go back to
that 80 billion figure just imagine if
we had 80 billion pounds to spend on
public services and tax cuts but we have
to pay that back because it is the
interest of the debt that we oh the huge
amount the two trillion pounds overall
but he uh that Richard sunak has talked
about uh Innovation investment in the
economy education he's done a lot
already on skills he rocket boosted the
apprenticeship program he's invested two
billion pounds to increase our skills
base because we have a huge amount of
adults in our country with
um illiteracy and enumeracy uh
difficulties so the chancellor when it
counts cuts the cost of living but is
doing so responsible play but is also
investing in our economy in skills as
I've just described it's
more of the same it's continuing the job
he was doing as Chancellor I mean he
earlier this week about being the heir
to Thatcher and promising to deliver
radical reforms we haven't had any
radical reforms have we what are they
going to be
well Margaret Thatcher also uh reduced
the debt that actually had to increase
taxes when she got in when the economy
was in a very difficult Place way back
in the 1980s and Margaret Thatcher
talked about good housekeep you can't
spend what you don't have and that is
what the chancellor is going to do to
reduce inflation and to invest in our
economy to invest in skills and
education I think that is the right
approach rather than having unfunded tax
cuts when you need to reduce the debt
fund on public services and make sure
that we get inflation under control
your chair of the education selection
committee are you concerned that Liz
trusses plans for the economy could mean
that spending on schools will fall
well it's up to
um other candidates Liz truss or
whatever to set out her own spending
proposals quite deeply about education
and we need to fund our schools and our
colleges and our universities and this
goes back to the argument I've been
making throughout this interview that
you can't just have unfunded tax cuts
because you have to deal with the debt
we have to spend money on the Public
Services whether it be the NHS education
and many other areas in public life and
if we have to we're going to have a
proper education service that needs to
be a properly a resource if you just
have unfunded tax cuts where is that
money going to be for Vital Public
Services
would Liz trust make a good prime
minister
very proud that all the candidates who
stood for leadership have have talent
and of course I'm sure
um that she would make a good prime
minister but I'm supporting uh I wish
you soon act because he's trusted in a
crisis he's going to be responsible
about the economy and cut inflation cut
debt and then we'll be able to do work
to cut the cost of living but he's also
helped the public when it counts uh
particularly those who are a lower
earners and more vulnerable but those
people are more vulnerable across our
country
Robert Hoffman we appreciate your time
thanks very much indeed for talking to
us this morning
thank you
and a reminder that a head-to-head uh
debate is going to take place here on
Sky News and a live televised debate
between the two candidates Cape early
will be hosting the program on Thursday
the 4th of August at 8 00 PM so don't
forget about that one
let's take a look now at all the stories
that are making the front pages of the
newspapers this morning and the
telegraph is reporting the Richie sunac
has insisted that if he becomes prime
minister he won't cut taxes until late
next year
and it's the same story in the guardian
which also reports that polling shows
list truss is well ahead of Mr sunak
the times reports that the two
candidates are trading blows over tax
pledges
morden's Revenge the eye says that Penny
Morden supporters intend to mount a
campaign to stop mistrust getting the
top job
the Metro leads with the BBC's apology
in court at the former Royal Nanny Tiggy
leg Borg over the corporation admitting
that its former journalist Martin Bashir
lied about her to Princess Diana in
order to secure his now famous interview
and it's the same headline in the star
we let Diana down
and this is the express which says the
BBC issues an apology over what it calls
shameful Panorama smears
the mirror quotes Diana's brother
calling for criminal charges against the
people responsible for the wrongdoing in
the case
and the financial times reports that the
European Central Bank has raised
interest rates by half a point that's
the first increase since 2011.
do you say with this thought come on the
show I'm going to be joined by a
Democrat strategist to get more reaction
to the capital Riot hearings
and with the country set to embark on an
estimated 90 million Journeys by car as
the school summer holidays start this
weekend I'll be speaking with the RAC
about what we should expect on the roads
plus I'll be joined by Shadow policing
Minister Sarah Jones to get her party's
take on the conservative leadership race
foreign so fuel price protests are set
to unleash Chaos on major roads as
millions of families head off on their
summer holidays an estimated 18.8
million Leisure trips are planned by in
the UK between Friday and Monday as
authorities warn of widespread
disruption well Madeleine Radcliffe
joins us now from close to the M4 where
protesters have said they are going to
Target so a huge number of pressures on
our roads then this weekend Maddie
yes that's right I mean I am standing
overlooking the M4 and it's likely to be
one of the pinch points for travelers
today there's two things going on here
really the first is yesterday schools
broke up it's the official start of the
summer holiday season and the RAC has
dubbed it in fact the great getaway
because it says nearly 19 million uh
Leisure Journeys will be made between
now and Monday that's more than any time
since 2014 and that's probably boosted
in part because we've seen so much
disruption at airports and air travel
over the summer so you've got more
people opting for staycations and but
sadly the other thing is there is likely
to be disruptions there's been warnings
of disruption on the roads today because
fuel price protesters are going to
Target motorways with flow trailers are
very slow moving cars the groups are
slow-moving cars that will clog up the
motorways here on the M4 but also the
M32 the M5 to protest about the very
high price of fuel at the moment so it's
a bit of a perfect storm if you're
trying to get away and we've already
seen huge disruption for Holiday makers
who are trying to leave our Shores down
at Port of Dover there have been three
hour cues for people trying to get
through security and get checked in so
it's not going to be an easy weekend and
certainly it's the RAC has said roads
across the country could become really
congested the advice is leave early if
you can't leave now leave before 10
o'clock in the morning or travel after
seven o'clock tonight to avoid the worst
of that traffic okay lovely madam thanks
for much indeed and I am going to be
talking to the RAC in a bit as well so
we'll get more words of wisdom from them
too thanks very much indeed
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other headlines and prisons across
England and Wales will soon have
specialized Wings dedicated to treating
drug addiction the government has
announced that it's putting 120 million
pounds worth of funding into the project
which will continue to support prisoners
once they're released
more than 7 million payments of 326
pounds have been made so far to help
low-income households through the cost
of living crisis according to government
figures it means 2.4 billion pounds has
been paid from the support package with
the second installment of 324 pounds to
be sent out later this year
one of the UK's most notorious prisoners
Charles Bronson has become the first
prisoner to formally ask for a public
parole board reforms came into Force
yesterday meaning parole hearings can
take place in public for the first time
Bronson who's been in prison for nearly
50 years recently sent Sky News a voice
message asking why he was still in jail
in Sri Lanka organizers say at least 50
protesters have been injured and a
number of journalists have reportedly
been beaten by Security Forces as
anti-government demonstrations continued
overnight outside the president's office
in Colombo earlier this week Randall
Wick Rama singer was sworn in as the new
president after months of Economic and
political turmoil
a hundred thousand monkeypox
vaccinations have been produced in the
UK as cases of the disease continue to
rise there are more than 2 000 cases in
the country and campaigners want more
people to get vaccinated
the UK health and Security Agency
predict about 50 000 people will need a
vaccine but the British Association of
sexual health and HIV predict at least
double that if not higher we reckon
about 125 000 minimum so this is a
really good step forward but keep
ordering those vaccines and keep getting
them into people's arms
turkey says a deal has been reached with
Russia to allow Ukraine to resume
exports of grain through the Black Sea
it's set to be signed later today in
Istanbul by officials from Ukraine
Russia turkey and the U.N Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez the world
shortage of Ukrainian grains since
Russia's invasion in February has left
Millions at risk of hunger
U.S President Joe Biden has tested
positive for covid the White House says
he's experiencing very mild symptoms and
that he'll continue to carry out his
duties while in isolation
hey folks guess you heard this morning I
tested positive recorded but I've been
double vaccinated and double boosted
symptoms are mild and uh and I really
appreciate your inquiry and your
concerns but I'm doing well getting a
lot of work done going to continue to
get it done and uh and in the meantime
thanks for your concern and keep the
faith it's going to be okay
now the heat wave the scene temperatures
soar in parts of Western Europe shows no
signs of relenting wildfires have swept
across France Spain and Portugal with
thousands forced to leave their homes
despite having more of the
infrastructure to cope with hot weather
some people fear that their homes May
soon become unlivable
well Spain is already experiencing its
worst year for wildfires in a decade
with more than 90 000 hectares of land
burnt Sky's Hannah Thomas Peter reports
from the Villages of obario and ovega de
cascala
when the wildfires surged through the
hills and towards the Tiny Village of
obario in Galicia Northwest Spain it
stood little chance
not even the Stone Church hundreds of
years old survived unscathed
oh no
Amparo corcobar has come back to see
what is left of her life
the house is still smoldering and it's
not safe to go back inside
she doesn't even know if they can
salvage anything
it's very sad very sad indeed she says
my husband inherited this house from his
parents and he built this bit with his
own hands when he was young to make it
bigger for my husband this really hurts
him and it hurts me too much
is a crisis to recover from but
increasingly a bigger problem to think
about too
as climate change gets worse so will
Fire season putting these communities at
risk over and over again and it will
make some people think about whether or
not they want to stay here at all
in the neighboring Village of avega De
cascala one family has had enough
it's the house that my father-in-law
built and it's our family home Lila
Rodriguez tells me but Our intention is
to sell it
it's a pity
but others like Roberto Rodriguez are
more philosophical
as everything has already burned he says
what is Left To Burn I am old and
retired where should I go
[Laughter]
I still have a beautiful house
for the moment that is true but others
weren't so lucky and must pick up the
pieces facing an uncertain future as the
danger posed by climate change grows
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in Galicia
in Spain
coming up on Sky News break first I'm
going to be joined by a former U.S state
senator and Democrat strategist to get
more reaction to the capital riots
hearings that's coming up
[Music]
welcome back you're watching Sky News
breakfast now in the last half an hour
the conservative MP Robert Halford has
told this program that his choice for
party leader Rishi sunak will close the
gap on Liz truss once he gets a chance
to pitch his ideas to party members he
also told me
that the former Chancellor isn't making
taxation promises that he can't keep
I believe that when the child the former
Chancellor which soon act makes his case
that more members will come and support
him because they know uh that he's not
making promises that he can't keep and
that's the important thing if he wants
to be popular he could say uh everything
and anything about tax cuts
or Rob is back with me now and the
context for this of course a poll which
is not very pretty reading for Rishi
sunai this morning yeah as we enter this
second part of the membership
um contest the leadership battle
um it shows that Liz truss at the moment
certainly appears to be the clear
favorite and the pitches are really very
different whilst on the trust side you
have talk of immediate tax cuts cuts a
reversal of that National Insurance rise
from earlier this year cuts to business
tax Corporation taxes the pitch from the
Rishi sunak side actually there's not a
lot new on top of what was put out while
he was Chancellor that is there and and
I think the The Proposal the proposition
that you heard Rob Halford setting out
there is essentially look this may not
sound as sort of eye-catching or
exciting but this is more realistic and
this is more sensible and that you
should trust me to put this through
because I know what I'm doing
essentially now the danger for that is
that this yougov poll shows that four
and ten of the 700 old Tory members that
they surveyed said they didn't trust
Rishi sunak to tell the truth so that
suggests that he has got some work to do
bluntly over the summer probably on two
fronts to firstly convince people that
he is a safer bet that he will not be
putting forward unfunded tax cuts that
what he he knows what he is doing and
his opposite number doesn't that's the
first part but bluntly the second bit is
probably offering something new a couple
of days ago he wrote a piece in the
telegraph talking about putting forward
radical reforms akin to the thatchy
years now when you push Robert Halford
on exactly what they are because he
hasn't said anything specific he didn't
say anything he just pointed to previous
policy so I think that you'd Hope anyway
if you were a Rishi sunak supporter that
there is something that he is holding
back to try and get people on side along
with essentially working on this issue
of trust and this this question of look
you might not like my message but trust
me that I know what I'm doing I think
that is the challenge the coming weeks
but being no doubt he is the underdog at
the moment and I think that's a
remarkable State of Affairs looking back
over the past previous months where I
think going back a few months you would
have probably assumed he would have been
the favorite in this but at the moment
it is list trust that is leading the
pack on this very interesting stuff yeah
Rob thanks very much Dean we're going to
be talking to a list trust supporter
very shortly as well
now critically endangered Pine Martins
could be reintroduced to the southwest
of England following a 150 year absence
now a coalition of conservation
organizations including the National
Trust hope that these nocturnal mammals
pictured here could be released as early
as Autumn 2024. now Pine Martens used to
be amongst Britain's most common mammals
but they were pushed to the brink of
Extinction in England due to a loss of
habitat
to find out uh their concerns but also
how we can work with them to resolve
those uh it's we've already been in
touch with over 70 organizations and
groups and we plan on working with them
over the next year to 18 months to work
through those concerns and issues and to
make sure this is successful
reintroduction for them and for the
animal
first with the country set to embark on
an estimated 19 million Journeys by car
it's a school summer holidays start this
weekend I'll be speaking with the RAC
about what we should expect on the roads
foreign
climate change is with us and it's
becoming critical but the fight back is
on coal is under Fire whereas wind power
is booming you can now have burgers made
out of these rather than those and no
need for fuel just rely on the vital
spark I'm Tom Heap and I'm joining Sky
News for special weekend editions of the
climate show where we'll meet the people
hit by the crisis but also those
delivering crafty Solutions in the end
the question is can we reach a world
that isn't based on
burning stuff
find out on the climate show on Sky News
now schools in England and Wales break
up for the summer holidays the RAC has
predicted there's going to be close to
19 million Leisure trips made by car
over the coming weekend it's the rac's
highest prediction for the summer term
breakout weekend since 2014. so joining
me now is Rod Dennis from the RAC so why
so busy
over the next few days it does look like
it's kind of the continuation of the
staycation Summers that we've seen for
the last two years we do think perhaps
some of the sort of the high prices the
sort of travel chaos actually involved
in traveling abroad this year might be
having an impact as well clearly fuel
price is still a big issue for people
over here in the UK but clearly if
you're going further afield into Europe
that only sort of adds up in terms of
adding on tolls and that sort of thing
so I think there is a kind of an
acknowledgment from drivers that yes
they want to get away on a trip or
perhaps stay more local this year makes
a lot of sense still
so a huge number of people taking to the
roads to go on holiday I mean to what
extent is that picture complicated
further by the fact that there could be
some protests on our roads
yeah I'm afraid I think later on this
morning and into this afternoon I think
there is likely to be an impact
um our friends at inrix who provide all
of all of the traffic data for us do
pinpoint that particular kind of stretch
around what we call the almondsbury
interchanges where the M4 and M5
motorways meet north of Bristol that's a
really important stretch for taking
people from the West Midlands and from
even from the southeast as well down
towards the West country and there is
likely to be some impact on drivers
heading sort of South there into the
early part of the afternoon
outside sort of that area you know the
fuel protests don't appear to be
affecting for instance the M25 and it's
really the M25 this year that features
is probably the road that appears to be
picking up most of the congestion a lot
of problems we expect between half a
cheer down to the M3 and between Bromley
and the Dartford crossing over the next
few days as well so I think it's going
to be a busy picture out there the
message for drivers is you've got to
leave early if you've not you're
watching this and you haven't left yet
and you've got a long journey planned I
think expected just to take longer than
you would normally expect time of year
it's really difficult for people isn't
it because they don't want to miss any
of their holiday but at the same time
they don't want to get spend the first
day stuck in traffic I mean if everyone
heeded your advice and left early that
you'd have you've had queues of traffic
on motorways earlier in the morning how
do people know when is the best time to
leave
I think that's a fair point I think we
have to sort of acknowledge it in this
country we have you know an important
but still limited Motorway Network the
sort of places where people want to go
and we know that every year the West
country Devon and Cornwall tops the list
for drivers sort of favorite locations
there are only a few means of actually
getting there it's the M5 and if you're
heading from the home counties in London
it's the a303 and we know there's
limited capacity on both of those roads
when things get extremely busy but then
short of sort of driving the middle of
the night was probably some particularly
palatable for a lot of people getting
away as early as you can is the best way
of avoiding the news you're not going to
perhaps avoid them completely especially
if you're traveling a long distance but
during the holidays people tend to get
up slightly later they tend to get out
onto the road slightly later as well and
it's that cumulative impact that leads
to some of the problems that we tend to
see so again you know early bird catches
the worm I think is still the key by
word but you've got to get away earlier
I mean super early to avoid those
and what about the risk of breakdown I
mean the worst nightmare stuck in
traffic and then you break down on a
Motorway causing even more chaos for
those people behind you do you have any
tips for people to avoid that risk
absolutely that's a great question our
patrols will go out to about three
quarters of a million separate
breakdowns over the course of the next
six weeks or so a large proportion of
those are avoidable and I think this is
frustration for families when they find
themselves involved in a breakdown but
there are things that you can do to
reduce the chance about happening in the
first place it takes you five ten
minutes this morning so under the Bonnet
with a cold engine check your oil and
coolant levels are where they should be
that only takes a few moments but it's
vitally important especially when the
traffic gets particularly heavy outside
the vehicle your tires make sure they're
free of damage and they've been inflated
correctly if you just follow those four
quick short steps the chance of breaking
down is reduced massively so I would
really urge everybody's trying to do
that this morning before they set out
so good advice on avoiding breakdown
what about good advice for avoiding
family breakdown in a car people with
small children traveling a very long
distance I mean this is perhaps beyond
your remit but do you have any advice
for people who are going to try and want
to make the journey as smooth as
possible
well I think you have to kind of
anticipate that it's going to be a long
trip you know you may not be driving to
France this summer but if even if you're
just heading down to Devon or Cornwall
up to the Lake District Yorkshire
wherever it may be just expect your
journey to take longer don't sort of
trust the first estimate that your Sat
Nav gives you and presume that you're
going to be there and on a good kind of
allowance into that an hour maybe even a
couple of hours just expect your journey
to take longer plan in plenty of rest
stops have some games snacks those sorts
of things at least the heat cool down so
you know if you're not in an
air-conditioned car at least sort of
conditions on the road are slightly more
comfortable but as you say you just
don't be in the situation of having a
breakdown because that clearly adds on a
huge amount of time stress and
frustration for everybody so try to
avoid that if you possibly can but yeah
it's not going to be particularly easy
of course the next few days but at the
same time people are desperate to get
away on their holidays
um you know our patrols will be there to
sort of help them on their way should
they run into difficulty but get away
early do your checks and hopefully
you'll have a reasonably straightforward
trip well Rod Dennis we appreciate your
advice and uh yes I join you in wishing
everyone very happy halls and uh hope
that it gets stuck in traffic cues for
too long thanks very much indeed thanks
and actually in some traffic relating uh
related news uh some breaking news in
the last few minutes Doug Bannister
who's the chief executive of the port of
Dover has told Sky News that there's a
critical incident going on at the port
at the moment with extremely long cues
there let's get more on this our
correspondent Madeline Radcliffe can
pick up on this she's covering the wider
travel disruption for us this morning
but uh news that uh Port of Dover is
struggling
yes thanks Anna the disruption starting
slightly earlier than we we thought or
hoped I suppose for drivers today that
critical incident at Dover because of
incredibly long queues forming there
already and as you said there uh the
chief executive of the port of Dover
Doug Bannister has told Sky News that
it's the cause of the cause of the
problem is the French their immigration
controls there are not properly staffed
he says and along with those Staffing
shortages and a longer transaction time
longer time for checks at the moment
that means there are already cues and a
backlog are developing and he says they
feel incredibly let down because they've
been planning for this day the start of
the summer holidays for months obviously
um but it sadly is already going to be a
tricky start for the day for those
trying to get away on some holidays with
this critical incident and very long
cues at Dover if you're trying to get
over to France
Madeleine thanks very much indeed so far
the traffic behind you looks fairly
free-flowing but uh who knows how it
will build up during the day Madeleine
thanks very much indeed
so that's the traffic news what about
the weather now let's take a look
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the next few days will be fairly
unsettled but over the weekend the
southeast looks mainly fine and very
warm it's a largely dry start but Cloud
over Britain is giving showery outbreaks
of rain especially across England and
Wales Britain will stay quite cloudy
through the morning with the best of any
Sunshine across the far south west and
Kent Sherry rain will develop more
widely with heavy and fundry downpours
possible especially in the south island
and Northern Ireland will stay mainly
fine
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
and before we go this hour a new
photograph of Prince George has been
released to mark his ninth birthday the
third in line to the throne is seen
smiling on a beach there he is in an
image that was captured by his mother
The Duchess of Cambridge earlier on this
month so happy birthday to him
do stay with us coming up next on Sky
News breakfast uh more as a Committee
hearing has been told Donald Trump
refused to call off the mob attacking
the capital building in January despite
police remembers of Congress and even
his own family
[Music]
[Music]